never have I ever made money performing
on the street far as I'm gonna go to
that doctor that we call yep mm-hmm
come on yes we have I'm on with I have
played never have I ever probably in
high school this be the first time sober
it's a fun let's do it
I have fallen off a mechanical bull just
grows all around really I hurt more than
I I'm not vulnerable I can't stay on
those sober or not I don't want to lie
cheated on a joke I'm eager with my
Spanish laughs terrible my driving tests
actually hope you're not watching the
car become vehicles most them I'm not
don't know not gonna would we're someone
somewhere see that's how it broke my
hand I was knocking on the lid ha ha
suck it I have definitely written a song
about a Texas Thunder oh yeah I'm
telling to but Taylor did it so
apparently we dated the same person
of course the whole first album never
ever piss off a songwriter not even with
permission cuz I don't want to know
sorry
[Music]
one song that I always remember crying
to Aerosmith I don't want to miss a
thing
absolutely for me it was a house that
built me Randall Lambert the mine was a
Brad Paisley song that he didn't have to
be broke me down to nothing I've never
used a fake ID oh I definitely used a
lot of fake IDs it didn't work out well
for me people kind of knew I was in the
time I was 15 I don't think that would
have worked I have used one yes but it's
been a long time ago she'd Protel I know
I look like I'm 21 but I'm really a
little older 27 several several
near-death experiences I have the bus
almost went off the road last month I
was in a car accident the car like did
like three spins and we went into the
woods
I don't wear neck brace to freshman year
of high school is this all somebody's
husband coming home just kidding
[Music]